[Music]
foreign
do you use Google Cloud armor and want a
better understanding of the
functionalities available
are you using load balancing and want to
block unwanted traffic as close to the
edge as possible before it reaches your
back end workloads and services
stick around as we introduce this go
deep with Cloud Armor Series and how it
can help you protect your network Google
Cloud armor helps you protect your
Google cloud deployments from multiple
types of threats it provides a cloud
service for advanced protection of web
applications services and apis against
distributed denial of service DDOS
attacks layer 7 application attacks like
cross-site scripting SQL injection and
fraud from Bots
at Planet scale for hybrid multi-cloud
architectures
Enterprises are now able to protect
their Google Cloud workloads across a
wide variety of native services and
workloads running on-prem and in other
clouds
for on-prem workloads this can be done
through VPN or direct connect and
workloads on another cloud service
provider can be covered via their public
IP addresses Cloud armor has been able
to protect from some of the largest
attacks ever experienced at L7 which you
can learn more details about in the blog
post Linked In the description Cloud
armor is configured as security policies
there are a couple different types of
security policies depending on which
resources you're looking to protect
back-end security policy which is
associated within https load balanced or
TCP SSL proxy load balance back-end
service and Edge security policy
associated with Cloud CDN enabled
back-end buckets or with media CDN
enabled Edge cache service
within each of these policies you can
Define and prioritize many rules Cloud
armor rules can be as simple as an IP
address filtering expression an advanced
match condition with multiple
sub-expressions or are pre-configured
Waf Expressions to help block attacks
like the owasp top 10.
so now that we've covered the overview
let's review what the series will cover
in this series we'll run through
demonstrations of how Cloud armor can
help keep you safe first we'll cover
configuration steps for rules and
policies monitoring and dashboarding and
infrastructure as code Automation and
secops workflow Integrations but before
we can dive into the videos for specific
topics we need to cover the hypothetical
architecture setup that we'll be using
to base our demonstrations on this is
the architecture for the imaginary
company we'll be protecting it has three
independent applications denoted here as
app one app2 and app3 the clients are
shown connecting to these applications
respectively app one and app2 happen to
be running together on one load balancer
and have different virtual IPS or VIPs
and separate application backend
Services running app3 was recently
acquired and will continue running as an
independent application but since Cloud
armor is highly embedded into our Global
load balancing infrastructure the policy
can be applied at load balancing level
and be associated with one or multiple
back-end Services wherever those
back-end workloads may be instantiated
in the world
I also want to point out that app2 is
hosted in a hybrid Cloud environment as
I mentioned before Cloud armor provides
cloud-based defense wherever your
application is deployed be it on premise
co-location Google cloud or any cloud
provider
for this to function we can set up a
network endpoint group and point it at
the application which allows for easy
integration of the services in this
hybrid environment now that we have the
setup for our Cloud armor demonstrations
we can begin to show you the details in
our next video we'll tackle configuring
rules and policies
make sure to subscribe to our channel so
that you get notified each time we put a
video out for this series let's go deep
with Cloud armor thanks for watching
[Music]